they were told to get off the streets
they were told to stay at home by the
authorities
but the anger and frustration felt by
many in nigeria
has spilled into the city of lagos
it's been building over the course of
the past two weeks
a protest against an unpopular police
unit
has turned into something else a
challenge to the government's ability to
rule
unnecessary and today in africa's
biggest city
buildings were torched a bus depot burnt
at a tv station attacked by agitators
forcing the staff to flee they started
attacking us inside the studio i had to
cut off the shoe
and we couldn't go up we can't continue
the show right now i don't even know
what to do
but
a strict curfew was introduced by the
state government
but the security services have struggled
to enforce it
we spoke to a resident of an inner city
suburb
the streets are littered with burnt
tires
all over just to hinder the military
from free patrol
what has it been like a couple of
nigerian youth
are in the hospital currently in pains
suffering from from results of
straight bullets shot directly to
unarmed protesters
this city-wide uprising was triggered by
a military-style assault on
demonstrators at their central meeting
point
at a toll gate in the city
members of the security services tried
to clear it
using live rounds sit down sit down
amnesty international says it has
credible evidence
of fatalities at the scene however
the state governor who visited some of
the 30 or so thought
injured has disputed that we are
comforted
that we have not recorded any fatality
as against the wild spreads circulation
on social media youthful demonstrators
have been calling for the disbandment of
the police's
much despised special anti-robbery squad
or sars and the shooting of protesters
has drawn intense worldwide condemnation
i'm not the kind of guy that talks about
politics
but i can't keep quiet anymore for what
is going on back home in nigeria
i would say nigerian government you guys
are ashamed to the world
protesters have returned to the lecky
tollgate
in lagos it's become a symbol of their
movement
and the sacrifices they have made john
sparks
skir news